parís y tres de sus departamentos
limítrofes están en alerta máxima el
virus avanza rápidamente así lo
indicaron las autoridades locales
durante una conferencia de prensa en la
que dieron a conocer las diferentes
medidas que entran en vigor a partir de
este martes y por espacio de 15 días la
principal de ellas bueno pues que los
padres tendrán que cerrar sus puertas
así como los gimnasios las salas los
salones de eventos todo tipo de fiestas
estudiantiles quedan prohibidas así como
las reuniones de más de diez personas en
la vía pública para visitar a los
adultos mayores en las residencias o
ancianatos tendrán que hacer para que
hacerse solamente con una cita previa y
en la sede de universidad es allí donde
se está presentando el 30 por ciento de
los focos de contagio en la región el
aforo será máximo de 50 por ciento que
se halla en los comedores como en los
salones de clase por otra parte los
restaurantes sí podrán continuar
atendiendo público pero tendrán que
hacerlo siguiendo un protocolo sanitario
mucho más estricto los lugares como
teatros los cines los museos estos
podrán continuar con las puertas
abiertas y también los estadios con un
aforo máximo de 1000 personas esto
quiere decir que no habrá un impacto
sobre el torneo roland garros ni tampoco
sobre los partidos de fútbol y rugby
programados en los próximos días cabo
estos 15 días el 19 de octubre para ser
exactos con las autoridades revisarán
todo este paquete de medidas para saber
si las mantienen o no todo dependiendo
de que hayan mejorado los diferentes
indicadores de la epidemia